hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another cry of fear
custom campaign hotel tear or that's not
anymore like a rock concert anyway hotel
terror it's raining O'Dell
hey Simon long time no see you crazy
psychotic bastard
let's see you are now leaving Fairfield
County please come back
we equipped your company what we
equipped your company I don't know what
that means right so anyway I guess his
car broke down so now he's just lost in
the woods and what's this a parking lot
of sorts where's my bed the weeping
beach in alright then the gate is locked
[Applause]
the gate is now locked
hmm welcome to the hotel of terror
yes everyone shouldn't I be in the hotel
I don't know I'm getting there
geez impatient douche what set up their
prime plan or something
no biggie hello everybody
oh wow are things about to get weird huh
Oh No did door locked aiya
what Oh voice acting or is that just a
snippet you got from before probably I
have to find a way out of here no you
don't it's perfectly nice we are haunted
thank you thank you for letting me know
that I'm that's so nice of you
all right anyway I'm starting to weed
through the old cry of fear saves hello
the door is locked
the door is locked I don't have any sort
of flashlight or anything like that just
yet door is also locked everything is
locked all locked awesome ooh not locked
what a change hey wha hey now don't be
booby banging no don't be banging on my
doors I guess I'm supposed to go down
here oh it's locked now of course all
right here we are windows open
look rain streak that's nice rusty
well isn't that lovely I still can't see
anything I have a feeling something's
gonna jump out at me I must save often
because I don't know what they're gonna
throw it at me so I have a key about
that must be for one of the motel rooms
[Music]
oh hello all right who's in there ah I
don't want to see what's in here first
probably a bad idea this is my room
[Music]
I remember that doobie banging who be
bragging oh you know like oh this looks
lovely if a bit hatched and
blood-stained oh look nice you son of a
[ __ ] I can't oh I can punch you oh god
crazy little douchebag look kid take
your lumps goodness yeah ugly God good
all right anyway I got a scissor half I
have one half of scissor now what does
that get me Oh God look Amir know what
dialogue look well that's me
doors locked this hotel is haunted
[Music]
it's Lucknow hotels not very big
yeah you heard me I have one half of
scissor now I need to get to other half
of scissor I don't know find that your
bid lubinski
Wow okay so can I like get out of here
now is that something that can happen
someone must have locked the interest I
don't know what I'm supposed to do now
[Music]
III III III III
III don't know can I go to sleep I'm
sure that'll turn out lovely for me okay
so I'm not sure I'm not exactly sure I
think I got everything
oh that's a lovely painting lovely
rendition of that I just have a feeling
that something's just gonna pop out of
nowhere because it usually does and then
I usually have to deal with it
Oh am I supposed to do so maybe I can
use it to open the doors okay that makes
that makes sense don't know how okay not
that one all right no already been
through there how about this --n ah
I have cracked the lock in the door I'll
crack the door lock good in the kitchen
looks like a rather homely kitchen for a
hotel
no-look syringe
why do I need this I don't I don't need
this
I want to get a look I forgot about that
Oh God won't you write the baby belly oh
yeah I'm not even I don't even see my
fist getting thrown I'm that skilled I
hit you with my mind bullets Carly
that's right fall over I could go
through that door the whole time are you
kidding me are you kidding oh god what
ones behind me can I get out of here
please please please please must be for
the entrance okay No oh my goodness oh
come on that's not fair it's not fair
where do I go how do i scowl don't tell
me this is like this is it or something
oh come on let me huh huh it's not fair
it's not fair
oh I gotta go down are you kidding me oh
you're kidding me Oh God Oh as for my Oh
God
holy [ __ ] just a dream no I doubt that I
need to get out of here yeah okay
and that is the conclusion which is how
they say the end in Sweden Island Simon
finally awoke from his terrible
nightmare what yeah in terms of terrible
nightmares that wasn't nearly as bad as
this other one you know where he
murdered everyone around him well no
that was only one of the possible
endings but still not bad not bad at all
I mean once again I would wish that
these people would just expand a bit
more but it's understandable then you
know they only have so much time doing
these early custom stories that are
coming on conscripted to go but you know
the support for custom stories is the
only recent so anyway overall accuracy a
hundred percent weapons found one damage
taken a lot time taking 810
I chose moderate not easy I chose
moderate you know you can't judge me
anyway that's all that's all we've got
for today so thank you so much for
watching click the annotations for more
videos that I've done comment on which
of these you want to see next and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye